-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night"
and I hope you're all
doing well.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden leaves tomorro
on his first foreign trip
since taking office
and, like all 78-year-old men,
that means he's already
at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
addressed potential migrants
in Guatemala during a news
conference yesterday and said,
"Do not come.
Do not come."
Wow, it's like she
read directly
from the Statue of Liberty
Wait. I swear to God
it used to be there.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Bill de Blasi
announced he's planning
a concert in Central Park
later this summer to celebrate
the reopening of the city
after the pandemic and this,
this is the guy you want
planning your concerts.
It's going to be that band
from the Viagra commercial
[ Laughter ]
then, a Jimmy Buffett cover band
called Jimmy Buffet.
Then, at 8:00 pm,
everybody, out of the park
or the cops move in!
[ Laughter ]
CNN yesterday obtained the audio
of a 2019 phone call made
by former President Trump'
attorney Rudy Giuliani,
in which Giuliani pressure
a Ukrainian official
to announce an investigation
into possible corruption
by then-presidential candidate
Joe Biden, but,
it's actually not a slam dun
for prosecutors.
See if you can tell why.
-I kind of think that this
could be a good thing
for having a much --
a much better relationship
where we really
understand each other.
[ Beep ]
-Thank you for calling
the Long Island Aquarium.
-See? That's the problem.
Your call is very
important to us.
[ Laughter ]
-Amazon's website was
temporarily down this morning,
due to an issue with their cloud
computing services provider,
but don't worry,
I'm sure that flight
into outer space next mont
will go great.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene on Friday
sent a letter to President Biden
that demanded he launch
an investigation
into Dr. Anthony Fauci
and provide answers
by June 31st,
a date that does not exist
Which is surprising,
considering the last thing
I would've expected her to d
is extend Pride Month.
Former President Trump is se
to go on a tour
with former Fox News host
Bill O'Reilly later this year.
Oh, better lock up
your daughters.
Seriously, though,
it's probably best if you do
You know, just 'til they'r
out of town.
The owner of a pub in Englan
recently discovered
a time capsule from the 1970
hidden in the walls of the bar
Locals are fascinated
because they've never seen
anything that new.
Nathan's Famous yesterday
began offering meatless hot dogs
and, for what it's worth,
it took Joey Chestnut
50 dogs before he noticed.
[ Laughter ]
So, pretty good.
The world's largest
Harry potter flagship stor
recently opened in New York,
which displays over 1,000 prop
from the movie series,
or -- and hear me out --
it's a hardware store.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, in a new interview,
sexual health expert Dr. Rut
said that 90-year-olds
should still have sex,
if they have a good partner,
but added,
"If you don't have a partner
they should satisfy themselves,"
so, now,
if you hear Grandpa
had a stroke,
maybe it's good news.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I'm not going to nam
the guy who wrote that,
but, if you watch this show,
you know who it is.
[ Laughter ]
Tank top!
Roots for the
New England Patriots.
[ Laughter ]
Favorite movie character i
Casey Affleck
from "Good Will Hunting."
[ Laughter ]
Ah, you guys,
that was the monologue.